chaque année durant les vacances de
printemps la ville de bois d'arcy
propose trois journées d'animations
cette fois ci les douze travaux
d'astérix sont à l'honneur et à l'image
de la bande dessinée les enfants doivent
en ce moment relever des défis sportifs
ou ludiques c'est ouvert tous les jours
depuis hier et déjà 300 enfants se sont
rendus au complexe jean moulin on écoute
l'une des animatrices
on a essayé oui d'allier vraiment toutes
les choses qu'à la fois les jeunes les
plus jeunes et les familles peuvent
faire partager avec leurs enfants
donc on a essayé d'y mettre un petit peu
de tout notamment né des animateurs qui
viennent un peu de tout horizon donc on
a réussi à rassembler un petit peu tout
ce que chacun sait faire autour de ses
activités et notamment sur les soirées
aussi qu'on propose là vraiment il ya
une valeur vraiment familial programme
complet sur le site de la commune et la
soirée de détente de clôture est
programmée vendredi à partir de 20h30